what we want typically is very almost
done sometimes unknown to us because
it's almost subliminal and it comes down
from our early backgrounds and so on we
almost have to discover what we really
want right and so when I think about
your background in terms of your dad
your mom and all of that journey I think
then your roots of what you want and
what you value came from there and yeah
I was raised in Harlem up my father was
killed when I was two almost three years
old and then my mother you know she she
had to figure it out and take over she
started working for jobs and that's
where I really learned my work ethic
from I would watch my mother get up in
the morning she would drive a school bus
then she would go and work in a clothing
store then she would go back drive the
school bus come home and feed us then
she worked with the United Cerebral
Palsy and she was a caretaker and I
never saw her sleep you know and it was
just it was just incredible so when I
was at the age of 12 years old I wanted
to step up and your Mount Vernon and
yeah and yes I was in my Vernon I went
from Harlem she moved us to a mom Vernon
cuz you know my father got killed you
know in Harlem and she just wanted a
fresh start for us and she made it
happen
and always sent me figured out a way out
of no way to send me to the best schools
and identified that I identified all of
the sacrificing that she did so when at
12 years old I was like I need to help
out and this is well this is the most
important stuff like I was lucky enough
to have two parents who loved me and
then I went to a public school and and
when you think about the fundamentals
and you went to like I think it was a
Catholic school right yes yeah yes I
went to Catholic schools all my life oh
my - I was an altar boy
you know and I went to Catholic school
in grade school then high school I went
to a Catholic school Mount Saint
Michael's I went to an all-boys school
so that kind of made me girl crazy
because all day long I was with boys I
got out and it was it was it was a you
know it was a unique experience I think
everybody's experience shapes them yeah
and when I was in before I got to high
school that's when I that's when I
started working I started like putting
you know a legal age on my resume and I
went home adopted up a birth certificate
so I could work because I mean I had I
had to do that I didn't wanna I wasn't
trying to be deceiving but I had to help
my mother I couldn't watch her work
herself to death and so I I began a
paperboy franchise we were talking about
because you were paper boy I was so you
know paper boy franchise and that kind
of taught me so much I would take the
all of the kids that were going to
college I would make a deal with them
give me your route and I'll send you
half of the money so I get them offer
they couldn't refuse so you know you get
six routes you know I started making up
to like you know five hundred dollars a
week and that was able to help out with
the house and grossed reason that that
that gave me a sense of of just like
pride that I was able to help help my
mother and my family and and and so from
that I just came like my mother had a I
had my paper route I was a gas station
attendant oh and I worked in a Mexican
restaurant and so that's kind of how my
journey began my journey began as far as
which a lot of people and and under
underserved communities you know its
survival but for me I was thinking
bigger I was thinking like you know I
wanted to
get to a point where you know where I
can make a difference and and and and be
something that represented my community
in a positive way because all the images
I saw on television and what I saw on
the streets growing up and in an era of
crack it wasn't it wasn't the most
appealing image of yourself if you were
black you know the communities were
flooded with drugs and flooded with guns
and it was a real real dark time it was
like The Walking Dead
and to make it up out of that and my
mother pushing me in and sending me to
Howard University you know it that that
when I wake up every day that's still a
part of my purpose I haven't like
graduated from that same Drive and that
same purpose that I had as a paperboy
you know so let's talk about culture
because culture is everything right
that's the mission and how you're
operating with yes yes what is can't
stop won't stop me in terms of your
culture tell me about the culture you
want yeah just from you know where I
come from there's so many times that you
actually want to quit you know where the
odds are so much against you that you
know you feel like you may want to stop
I'll pick a easier path or Road and
can't stop won't stop it's something
that I came up with in my music I would
drop these positive messages like when I
would be doing ad-libs on songs and it
was it's my movement it's that it's that
you know no matter what if you get
knocked down ten times get up 11 just
keep on getting up and keep fighting and
keep learning
and embrace the good times embrace the
bad times but I have something in me
that I can't stop you know there's times
when when I really I was running a
marathon and I didn't train for the
marathon so it was I trained eight weeks
you know I kind of used my pull in New
York to to get me a number to run the
marathon but I was i I just figured that
I could do anything and I didn't really
train properly in between I was still
partying making records up late at night
so marathon is 26.2 miles it's like you
know it is it's like life and so not
being prepared on the 10 mile I hit the
wall on the tenth mile where I had
sweated all of the sodium out of me and
so my body started to cramp up and I had
to look and I had sixteen point two
miles to go and I was thinking about
jumping in a cab I was trying to figure
like how can I get out of this and you
know III did the raised money the whole
mission was did he runs the City Stories
raised three million dollars for four
pub the public school system but it was
contingent from my friends on me
finishing the marathon and so they can't
stop won't stop was like if I have
breath in my body like I'm gonna keep on
getting up if I gotta crawl there was
points I was crawling and and it's just
it's just been a you know the the the
mantra the mission statement of my life
can't stop won't stop and um you know it
really has been a symbol of adversity
not just with the marathon through other
things that I've gone through and life
being a public figure and it's something
that that you know is my rallying cry
culturally also to to my culture to my
community that you know we're not going
to stop till we - we get the change that
we want and get the quality of life
we want and yes that there are
circumstances that weigh in but you know
if we keep on and keep being persistent
the doors may get slammed on your people
may not pick up the phone but don't stop
there's always a way there's always a
way there's always a way just cuz you
don't know what the way is doesn't mean
there's always a way you got to keep
looking at these things echo because not
only have I learned that but I find that
almost everybody who is successful has
learned this like my own mantra is
dreams plus reality plus determination
equals a set of successful life I had a
uncle shrimp
his name was a shrimp Nate named uncle
shrimp they called him shrimp because he
was kind of short okay it and one day we
came up with this with this this quote
and this original quote and it is don't
be afraid to close your eyes and dream
but then open your eyes and see that's
it so that's an original Sean Combs
uncle that's it and it's like don't be
afraid to close your eyes and dream but
then open your eyes and see the reality
of what it's going to take no matter how
insurmountable
it may look you've got it you reflect
you've got humility and you've gone
through experiences and all that you
know pain plus reflection equals
progress that that's a hero and now what
you really do have to do is write it
down and share it in the best way while
you're simultaneously doing the other
thing